[تصفيق]
نهايه سعيده وبدايه لحياه سعيده للطفل
شنوده الذي عاد اخيرا الى حضن اسرته
بالتبني امال وفاروق بعد رحله معاناه
للطفل والاسره امتدت لاكثر من عام
وقال يا ماما كفايه دي بالدنيا كلها
تفتكري مدام امال ان هو هيحتاج اي حد نفسي
يقعد معه يريحه بصي اكيد اكيد بس انا يعني
الاول او الكنيسه وكده
وربنا يتدخل بقى ربنا يكمل نفسك تشوفي
شنوده فين بيشتغل ايه عايزه شايفه مستقبله
انه يطلع دكتور كان كل ما حد يساله يقول
له انا اسمي الدكتور شنوده فاروق وفوزي
بولس غبريال اكبر جراح في مصر العالمي
شنوده الذي عثر عليه عام 2018 في احدى
الكنائس تبنته السيده امال وزوجها وبعد
اربع سنوات تقدمت احدى قريبات الوالد بسبب
خلافات حول الميراث ببلاغ كيدي بان الطفل
مختطف ولم يعثر عليه في الكنيسه الامر
الذي ادى الى ايداعه منذ عام في احدى دور
الرعايه ودخول الاسره في اجراءات قانونيه
وق انتهت بصدور فتاوى من الازهر ودار
الافتاء بان الطفل يتبع ديانه الاسره
المسيحيه التي وجدته في الكنيسه وصدور
قرار من النيابه بتسليم الطفل لاسرته
بالتبني طفل ده
كبيره
تعدله هذا الطفل لم تكن
قانون كلمه اسره مؤقته اثار
لان
المفروض اني ان الاسره تنهي اجراءات
الاسره البديله كل هذه الامور قد تستغرق
شهر او شهرين فكانت النيابه العظيمه
المحترة النيابه العامه يعني لديها من حس
الانساني والحس القانوني وبعد الانساني
قالت لا يعني احنا دلوقتي يقعدوا شهر على
ما يستكملوا الطفل بعيد عن ابوه والقرار
صدر فاحنا هندي مسافه مؤقته وهي بعد كده
تجيب الحاجات دي كلها وبحسب القانون فان
قرار النيابه اسدل الستار على ماساه طفل
لم يتعدى الخمس سنوات ليعود الى حضن الام
والاب بالتبني والذي لم يعرف غيرهما راندا
ابو العزم العربيه القاهره